on va passer à zone interdite heyer
javan humeur ou un numéro de zone
interdite très poignant c'était sur les
maisons de retraite maintien à domicile
le scandale des personnes âgées
maltraitées il ya beaucoup de sujets là
dessus actuellement on a vu des images
vraiment très prenante et ce sujet il a
énormément fait parler car il à montrer
l'envers du décor avec des images très
choquant comme je voulais dit vous a
préparé un petit résumé de l'émission
d'hier vous allez voir c'est très très
chaud dites-nous est-ce que ils ont été
trop trash sont interdites ou pas oui ou
non vous répondent également ces partis
hier soir dans zone interdite
ophélie meunier s'intéresser aux ehpad
un reportage dans lequel une journaliste
a réussi à infiltrer un de ces
établissements dans des conditions
surprenantes
nous rappelons que nous n'avons aucun
diplôme et aucune expérience dans le
milieu médical mais cela n'a pas l'air
de poser problème avec une mission
montrer au téléspectateur l'envers du
décor résultat des images chocs aussi
bien sur le traitement des patients par
le personnel
toul la résidente et sur les toilettes
dans une position humiliante
elle s'agace sur leur alimentation
[Musique]
c'est parce qu'elle soit encore sur les
séquelles qu'ils gardent de leurs
séjours à cause de ces chutes
récurrentes
le papa de sophie et couvert d'hématomes
et de claix bref un reportage qui n'a
pas laissé indifférent de nombreux
internautes choqués par ces images
alors selon vous ce documentaire
était-il trop trash c'est vrai qu'il ya
eu des images vraiment complètement faux
alors oui ou non
tiens lolo non je pense que au même
titre que l 214 et une associative était
public ça c'est formidable de le montrer
c'est horrible de le voir et c'est
formidable de le montrer parce que c'est
la réalité c'est parce que ça dénonce
une certaine réalité ça j'espère il ya
des maisons qui sont qui sont bien
malheureusement doivent être très cher
mais voilà c'est inimaginable
et c'est bien de le voir pour que les
gens règle les problèmes c'est vrai
qu'on parlait le travail du journaliste
là franchement l'aï eu un travail d'une
modiste incroyable c'est comme sur
envoyé spécial là vraiment il faut
dénoncer ça vous avez été choqué jean
michel maire oui parce que je trouve ça
ne s'adresse est pas la réalité comme
vient de le dire de finir c'est non non
tu pu faire un reportage sur n'importe
quel endroit n'importe quelle société
n'importe quelle entreprise tu peux
faire un reportage à charge et tuera des
images qui se consiste en des lieux
s'ils seront un horrible mais ça ne
montre pas le travail que font ces passé
personnel je trouve qu'ils font un
travail remarquable dans des conditions
difficiles alors oui il ya des luca
barla smartphones ils font un travail
remarquable et on nous montre qu'à
chaque fois que dans ce genre de repas
tarif que les choses qui sont à charron
une fois que ces montres pas des [ __ ]
moi je salue c'est pas honnête pour le
travail bref on sait le cerbère mais
jean-michel c'est comme avec envoyé
spécial quand quand c'est le sujet des
personnes âgées vous confondez tout là
la caméra cachée nécessaire c'est dur ça
fait mal mais c'est indispensable de
voir ça et si a pas de caméra cachée ci
a pas d'infiltration on n'a pas ce
risque à l'intérieur ils le savent pas
que les connexions sont effet c'est
l'extase et non ça va faire évoluer sa
saf est révolu bernard montiel qu'on n'a
pas entendu non je trouve que là c'est
une vraie réalité qu'ils ont montré la
moi malheureusement j'ai connu ça de
près pour revenir ça y est trop jeune
pas y aller
et mais j'y pense déjà et je regarde un
peu les maisons ah oui si vous regardez
les maisons moi je suis allé voir où il
fallait voir pour des raisons
personnelles je les vois comme être bien
les gens que j'aime là où il faut ça
coûte très cher d'avoir 50 ans minimum
de 1200 euros dire les seuls ceux qui
gagnent sont ceux qui construisent c est
pas si on te font des bénéfices
monstrueux il ya plus d'un million cinq
d'aînés défendant et un tiers de ses
aînés dépendants
c'est à dire les nos anciens elles sont
quand même dans des maisons dans ce
genre de maison et je vous assure que ça
des conditions épouvantables mais ce que
je dois dire ce sont tous les aides
soignants et tous les personnes qui
s'occupent de ces gens là ce sont des
gens brillants magnifique mais il y en a
ras le bol il n'y a pas assez de
personnel
nintendo qui deviennent et la
maltraitance elle devient un volontaire
du coup qu'est ce que j'ai fait pour
drucker type la soul au lembras
d'ailleurs michel qui nous regardent à
tous les jours aller les chiroux va voir
ce que vous en avez pensé de ça vaut
aussi est ce que vous trouvez que zone
interdite est allé trop loin 80% mardi
19 et 20 bravo oui car il faut abattre
et ses dérivés entendu